we have an exciting second day here of
the final the thrilling final between
wesley cell and
magnus carlsen so this is great
wonderful stuff
so let's see what happened in this game
i've already spilled the beans the first
move is
one e4 whoops happy birthday to magnus
carlsen who turns uh
30 years today the it stands
2-2 now and this is their first game out
of
four let's see how it went down
so e4 c6 from magnus the caracon defense
a huge surprise i must admit a huge
surprise but apparently wasn't very
content with the positions after e5 or
c5 for
for that matter so he decided to to
surprise uh
good old so here with uh c6 so let's
take a look
at what happened d4
d5 the uh the main line and wesley now
decides to go for
e5 uh the main move here is knight c3
well e5 is critical and also e takes d5
has become very popular
i like every move i think everything is
better for white
but that's another story wesley plays e5
and magnus responds to the main move
bishop f5 here
i think that move is slightly better
than the short variation of c5
which is of course possible but i think
that bishop f5 is a better try
bishop f5 knight d2 an interesting uh
try there are many lines here in
particular h4 is a critical move
where black usually responds with h5 and
we get the kind of
very complicated positions where white
tries to get
control of the dark squares and black
tries to get control of the light
squares
so um very interesting line here with h4
bishop bishop d3 certainly another move
here
what not bishop d3 sorry um
knight f3 and simply bishop e2 is kind
of a common approach
but it actually goes for knight d2 which
is another line
so these positions become very
complicated they become quite closed
so e6 knight b3 looks very strange but
the point is that he wants to prevent c5
and also the knight in general stands
quite good on b3
knight d7 knight of three and you're
like hey sebastian you said that he was
going to prevent
c5 and now he can already play c5 why
doesn't he do it well
that's certainly not a possible move but
now the extra option is that i can jump
to d4 with the knight even with this
knight
also there's bishop e5 stuff in the air
as well
so h6 that's kind of quite common you
want to give the bishop to h7 square
while g5 is sometimes
an option bishop e2 is simply developing
the bishop and here magnus goes for the
move a5
he simply wants to play a4 and kick away
this knight on b3
so wesley is forced to play a4 he cannot
allow that
we should before check magnus forces
wesley to play
c3 i'm not sure why he wants to do that
he just goes
goes back and he says that c3 is not
such a good move here
but i must admit i like c3 i'm happy
that i've gotten that for free
so maybe it would have been been better
to simply go for 97 or something
then perhaps g5 knight 26 lighter and
bishop b7 i do not think that
black should give white c3 for for free
but that's just
uh me so let's see bishop before c3
bishop f8
simple development with castles is
always good 97 there we go
h3 i think that's a good move as well
common move if you want to play knight
h2 perhaps even f4 g4
f5 start attacking and it's not so easy
for
for black but as i've had as i have
mentioned these positions
are quite strange they're very hard to
to understand
even i am struggling quite a lot with
both colors
but um let's see what happened here so
bishop h7
bishop d2 logical uh move you could go
to e3
as well i guess but you do not really
want to give the knight five of the
tempo
and if you give if you put play bishop
f4 even
g5 can be played by the tempos in some
cases as well
it could be maybe a little bit too
premature due to the fact that black is
poorly developed but
but you rather want to to put a bishop
on the place where it cannot be attacked
so bishop d2 is the logical
it's a logical move queen b6
another pretty logical uh move here it's
not so easy for me to move
my knight pawn on b2 will be hanging and
now my queen is also forced to protect
uh the knight as well which is
sometimes slightly annoying for for
white
so so the american goes for 91 here he
wants to play knight d3
knight c5 or even bishop d3 to trade off
these bishops
the bishop on h7 is actually quite
strong here
has a massive diagonal so bishop d3 is a
logical
it's a logical square to put the bishop
magnus goes for knight f5 it's time for
him to get the bishop developed
bishop to e3 the bishop is nicely placed
in their diagonal
bishop b7 queen c2 look at this diagonal
it's looking pretty good and g4 is
actually a threat so magnus has to
prevent that he plays bishop g6
and c4 by by wesley and this is
i'd say that it's a blunder i'd say that
he overlooks something
drastic here and this is a poor move
he should have been just waiting a
little bit more perhaps something like
it's not even easy to find a move here
something like bishop f4 it could be
possible now because the knight has gone
to
f5 and there is no g5 yet so bishop f4
is a move that you can make
maybe even rook c1 the thing is the
black is going to play c5 and it's not
that easy and these pieces are all
looking a little bit strange here so um
maybe the ship before something like
that and then try to improve your pieces
and it's a very interesting position i
will play g4 at some point black needs
to be prepared
i'd say it's a very double-edged and it
could go in
in any direction here very very
complicated stuff
uh i'd evaluate the position as i'm
clear but wesley goes for c4 and that is
a blunder
after d takes it for queen take c4 and
the beautiful move
knight takes d4 this is a very brilliant
because if i take back with my knight
now
magnus can play knight takes e5 and
we're attacking the bishop and queen
simultaneously
so it's not possible to take the knight
with the knight
if i take with the queen i'll take to
take oh never mind if i take with the
queen i can simply take on b3
for some insane reason i thought that
the um
the bishop here was not guarded of
course it's guarded by the nighttime new
one
it's been a long day don't judge me all
right uh so here knight takes d4
and um well then i might show why this
doesn't work because i just thought that
the bishop was hanging
as a matter of fact if i play queen c3 i
have bishop b4
if i play queen c2 i have queen takes d4
just in case you were wondering all
right
so i cannot take i have to take with the
queen
this happened in the game as well tweet
takes p3
bishop takes g6 f takes g6 and it's
we've gotten an entirely different
position here where
where magnus's king is slightly weaker
you could say but he has one upon and
the pawn on d4 is nice pawn to win as
well
white is stuck with this bishop here
which is sort of poor it's not very good
however it is not too shabby either it
has a future on
on c3 but i definitely prefer
for black here so queen e4
magnus simply ignores the threat of the
queen takes g6 i think that is very very
clever
if i now take on g6 knight takes e5
comps that would be very bad
but actually he goes for bishop takes h6
his point is that if this one is taken
he can take on g6 and this could even be
winning
i think it's winning for for white if it
takes
and something like rook c1 rook c3 rook
g3
it's going to be made at some point or
at least loss of material
so that wouldn't be possible magnus here
he doesn't take back he plays rook
f5 which is an excellent excellent move
wesley goes for bishop e3 you do not
want to play bishop f4 here because of
knight c5 and i think this is already
lost because i have rook t8 at the end
and this bishop is going to to fall
queen e3 and then something like
g5 this position is hopeless
bishop g3 simply take
yeah this is uh very bad look at all of
these weak pawns and
blacks active pieces huge advantage for
for black like minus six quite crazy
so you do not want to do that you want
to prevent you want to prevent knight c5
so bishop e3 is the move that makes
sense here
magnus plays the queen d5 and that is
slightly strange
you cannot take on b2 because of knight
d3
but you may wonder why can't you take on
e5 doesn't this look
logical well yeah but i can take on g6
and if i take with the knight i can then
play g4
and this knight will be unprotected on
e5
and the white will have a winning
position so magnus played queen d5 i
think this is a good move
queen takes d5 e takes d5 f4
and the very important move the only
move that leads to an advantage
advantage for black is the move g5 and
the point is
we are destroying this pawn center here
so if i play something like ticks
the pawn here is hanging and these pawns
will be
far far too strong in the end game
so i cannot take and if i play g3 to try
to keep the center
takes takes i can even play g5 here
looks uh possible to me but at least
something like knight of fate 96 looks
good and then rook f8 to put more
pressure on f4
would also be quite quite good but e6 is
the move that's played
now at c5 attacking on e6 g4
wesley goes all in and here's another
another brilliancy by magnus he is so
good in these positions it's
it's wild and of course he finds the
best move here
and that is to sacrifice the exchange
with gtx f4
very very well played gtex f5 f takes c3
rook f4 trying to get some activity here
and also
protecting a4 while preventing d4
bishop f6 slightly inaccurate
not the best move but certainly and not
a bad one either a better move would
have been to play rook fade i'm
threatening united c6 right now
and that's very difficult to prevent
something like
this makes sense but then i will just
play e2
and knight d3 and does look quite
hopeless if you ask
if you ask me
uh but bishop f6 is still good knight c2
e2 rook f2 and here
once again magnus is alert he plays d4
and his point is that if i take on e2 i
will then play d3
and if i do not do that well then these
pawns would just be running down the
board
so wesley takes it he's more or less
forced to do that
uh e d3 rook d2
d takes c2 rook takes c2 rook d8 and
this is uh
very good for for magnus he has now
gotten himself a winning position
after playing absolutely brilliantly in
the
end game there very very well played
very impressive
rookie one knight xa4 it's all falling
apart for
for the american after knight xb2 rook
takes a5
knight e3 and these pawns they can't
really do anything
so they're they're greatly blocked by
this bishop and these pawns will
eventually
roll down the board let's see what
happened king h2
knight before knight d5 i'm going to
play knight e3 at some point and take
this pawn on f5
rook a7 and simply rook b8 and now i'm
also going to play b5 b4 b3 b2 it's very
difficult to stop
king g3 97 good move because i now
protect c6 and i'm now i can
also i'm free to to play b5 while i'm
also attacking on f5
such a multi-purpose move king g4
b5 rook d1 b4
rookie 7 b3 you can simply run with the
pawn
there is never any checkmate so rook d8
takes takes
king h7 rook b8 but it doesn't help
after b2
the position is completely hopeless and
after 95
the american resigned
and rightfully so because the position
is completely hopeless
i'm going to play c5 c4 c3 and there is
nothing
white can do about it and the position
is winning
great start by the world champion
excellent start
it now stands um he has won the first
game
and a rumor has it that he did lose the
second game so
so the score is now one one very
exciting
to see what's gonna happen next stay
tuned for more
and i'll see you guys later